hast du die leiter hingeworfen die
lohnen die lohnen die lohnen die lohnen
die lohnen kommen
hallo freuen und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge captain frei kräften
der komme gerade vor der aufgabe einfach
mal ein ei geschmissen hat und es kam
einfach vier kleine hütchen raus da oben
sehen wir zwei hier unten laufen alle
her
warte mal ich probiere es nochmal 8 und
guck mal hier auf die ecke
naja egal aber ich habe mir in der
letzten folge bei komme wie es nicht
gesehen habt eine schon eine kleine
kiste gemacht wäre ich jetzt den
nebenstellen und da werde ich ein schild
rang platzieren und die werde ich essen
essen essen nennen einfach weil da kommt
unser ganzes essen weil wir mittlerweile
schon mal daran wir haben schon so ein
paar sachen die man auf jeden fall
verzehren kann ich jetzt ein paar dinge
ja schon eingepackt weil ich brauche auf
jeden fall nahrung
du hast du hast hier den bogen nicht
deswegen hab ich hab noch drei pfeile
für dich die schmeißt ihn einfach kurz
ins inventar schon neun freilich weiß
nicht ich möchte nicht mit ganz so
vielen pfeil in die hölle gehen weil
wenn wir ein archiv mit dort bekommen
und dann sterben und dann so ein bogen
mit 1000 teilen weg wäre wenn natürlich
hast du eigentlich eisen schwer ich habe
glaub ich noch rein ja ach so na gut
dann hab ich jetzt mal da denkst wir
können jetzt wieder in die hölle der
jetzt können wir in die hölle
willst du wieder auf jeden fall soll ich
mal probieren die du einfach voran
du kannst du sonst einmal die items
davor also fort bevor du da reingeht
einmal davor das portal werfen den wald
gemacht haben dann einfach ich schmeiße
jetzt einfach dieses steines und
cobblestone plateau hingestellt
münchen/mainz da wurde gerade drauf
steht ist oder was man ja genau weil ich
eigentlich ich wusste nicht dass wir
leitern haben und leitern bauen können
soll ich jetzt mal ganz alleine sache
mal bitte da liegen
da wollte ich eine wunderschöne treppe
machen ich bin drin funktioniert ich
gehe mal wieder zurück in meine sachen
gehe ich mal ein
wusstest du dass man im portal sein
inventar nicht öffnen kann er es wusste
ich sehr sehr interessant ist mir
aufgefallen so ich war mal eben das und
ich höre schon gast ach ist das geil
wir werden hier auch eine begrenzung ja
das fällt jetzt auch nachdem das fünfte
mal erhalten
ich bin ja immer direkt gestorben da
kann man sich auch hier ja auch noch
versteckte thrun
das will ich das war echt cool so wir
haben jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen
verknallt sondern wenig zusammen bleiben
ich nehme auch mal hier so ein getränk
eventuell später mal hier schon diesen
nenner quatsch ich weiß nicht das
braucht bestimmte später für alchemie
oder für was braucht man das kann sein
ja ich habe keine ahnung so das machen
wir nochmal eben kaputt ist aber ich
viel von dem zeug dafür zahlen wir hören
das ganze ja auch erstmal so aus wie wir
es in der höhle gemacht haben weiß klar
doch dann haben wir hier nämlich bleibt
also ein bisschen platz vor allem die
snack das ganze recht schnell abbauen
also ich paulas karte nicht mit den
diamant spitzhacke ab sondern mit der
eisen spitzhacke ich habe immer noch
damit niemand mitnehmen sollten also ich
glaub ich lasse sie brauchen ein kino
forbes die diana den rest alles auch mit
links ab und ich brauch erst mal soweit
ab wie es geht mit der begrenzung
atheistische liebe ganze sehr gut wie
schön die welt hier und begradigen die
ein wenig bauen paar treppen
ich laufe auch kann man so ein bisschen
rum ich mache das aber jeweils am
rumlaufen wenn du hier erkundet dann
komme ich mit nehme ich ihn wieder auf
doch bloß dass das denn
pass mal kurz bisschen nur dass hier
unter die abbauen
er passt mal ganz kurz auf ich will
jetzt ins cockpit nicht dass darunter in
villars vice oder so
in dieser sieht nicht so aus ja gut ich
nehme einfach so da ist noch ein los
dann und da noch nie da kann ich dann
genau da kommen wir später an
gut ich mal wieder bei mir da ein wenig
weiter ja ich gehe mal kurz in meinem
gang hier am rande das ganze jetzt
gerade erst mal ganz kurz
also ist auch schon pixo ja nicht
angreifen am besten nicht hast du denn
hier hatte gibt es nicht dafür wenn man
die angreift glaub schon aber parcours
aber ich glaub ich glaube das ist doch
nicht dafür braucht man erst die anderen
nicht wenn es also würdest du auf jeden
fall in der hölle brauchen wir diesen
lohn stab und ich gucke auch mal nach
hier kannst du schon nach unten gehen
genau man kann darunter aber auch hier
hoch oder blick zombie ist da würde ich
erst mal hingehen da ist nicht ganz weg
zum skelett ohne erfahrung getötet so
eine
all das gelernt hilfe kommen jetzt mit
vorstand wollen wir einfach mal hier
hoch gehen und man war sich sicher ganz
kurz meine die diamant spitzhacke mal
eben das was wir auf jeden fall noch
brauchen im projekt ich gehe mal ganz
kurz noch mal nach hause
jo ich brauche nur wir alles schon prima
cobblestone mit wenig glauben was ich
wollte den chor trägt mit der leiter
machen und deshalb senior krieg ich habe
alle meine sachen aber er war so müller
ich wollte dann hier in die leiter
rangehen aber ich habe es nicht
geschafft
unheilig vollidiot egal jetzt hab ich
einfach mal alle drei level verloren
habe ich jetzt noch aber sonst habe ich
alles noch glaube ich oder schauen mal
ganz genau ich alles noch an kraft
ich habe meine sachen verloren das habe
ich verloren
die vollidiot sofort gitter kommen du
feierst du vergisst auch echt wie wir
unsere kisten sortieren wollten direkt
ist nur die sache für wertvolle sachen
unterliegt auf einfach mal neuen leitern
und sand blog drittel sind überaus
erfreulich sein los mit doch wertvoll
weil ich machen uns mal eben noch ein
paar leitern damit wir in der hölle da
auf jeden fall meine schaufel mit bitte
der kleinste von the way so da noch ein
paar leitern so hier noch ein paar da
noch ein paar hier noch ein paar gut an
auf welche gleitern das sollte erstmal
reichen cobblestone hab ich jetzt für
jeden mac diesen nenner quartz dass ich
auch mal hier
dann wollte ich noch genau werkzeuge
machen
kann sein dass du richtig viel eisen
hast ich habe null gar kein eisen aber
in den ofen dürfte noch reisen
drinliegen
er liebt mich auch nichts mehr drin da
nichts mehr schauen wir ganz kurz so
nett doch da war noch was okay du gerade
noch mal richtig viel von diesem messer
quartz gefunden so dann mache ich jetzt
mal eben eine spitzhacke jan etwas hab
ich irgendwie auch schon 20 stück oder
wieviel warte ich habe ganz kurz 16
stück habe ich auch schon der kiste drin
sah ich habe jetzt ein gesuchter
normaler herrlich gestellt erschreckt
ich brauche jetzt gar keine hilfe mehr
aber seit ich direkt oder erschrocken
ich habe mich erschrocken als ich hab
mich erschreckt ich habe mich
erschrocken das fahrzeug seit ich
geboren bin dann hast du dich
versprochen so ich mache es mir hier
noch mal so eine kleine wand dass wir
nicht offen weil jetzt ist die world
bode ja schon so groß dass wir auf der
anderen seite aus einem portal ausfallen
würden deswegen möchte das war mal ganz
kurz ein bisschen dass man da nicht
rausfällt so war ja ich habe jetzt mal
eine treppe nach unten gebaut damit
wieder mal vorbeischauen können
wien ett ach so ja ich habe extra leiter
mitgebracht
die bringen uns hier nicht ganz so viel
weil wir hier gar keine steine haben wo
wir sie daran setzen können kommen
einfach mal wir hier die hölle wo ich
dachte gerade schon wieder du bist
gestorben
das dachte ich auch vor allem bei mir
als auch ich bin gerade auch von einem
block wieder runter gefallen alter das
krass das ändert alles irgendwie ein
bisschen an sky block mit diesen ganzen
treppen die stadtbau so gar keinen sinn
was ich gemacht da ich bin offen weg so
jetzt hier noch eben die paar blättchen
immer wieder auch noch ein stück hier
nahrung
ich bin unterwegs bin sofort ab jetzt
kommt sogar wieder
ja ich gehe eben hier auf entdeckertour
so was ich immer was ich gemacht habe
ich glaube als cooler obere unten wo
möchtest du als erstes sind oben
okay ich bin schon oben aber hier sei
nix nämlich wirklich das nochmal dieser
kurzen ecke da ostern den hole ich mir
mal kurz weg zum kloster oben hole ich
mir mal eben
ich glaube den klaus dann braucht man
den später fürs braun gerne ja kann man
verwenden so freiwillig den pick
zusammen wie mal angreifen bis sie
sicher okay es ist abgehauen
ich habe nicht mal die schwert alter ego
look
wir haben schon jolo gemacht hat wie das
portal gelaufen sind und gestorben sind
das war auch nicht so geil jolo 2 ich
weiß nicht was du mal bitte ganz kurz
die clowns da unten auf die darunter
gefallen sind okay irgendwo ich höre ich
höre übrigens lohan laut hier oben
die sind wahrscheinlich genau über die
musste ich nur nach oben buckeln ja die
sind wahrscheinlich direkt über diesen
großen oder sagst auch leitern dabei ja
54 wirft immer runter und baue ich mir
mal eben weg zu dir nach oben professor
denn die lohn die lohn
die lohnlücke schuss gehört wo warst du
die leiter hingeworfen die lohnen die
lohnen
die lohnen die lohn die lohn kommen wo
sind die lokomotiven stellen die nie
gelungen ein
trotzdem glaube ich stelle mich belogen
heute waren erzieherin außen bleiben
informiert wird
ich habe nur aus bogen stellte sie töte
dich los schnell ein schuss hat
getroffen
noch ein hart getroffen
nach einer hart getroffen er ist tot
okay aber wir haben auch kinder unter
uns ist noch was sind da kommt auch
gleich einer der treiber wie die puhdys
und ich hab noch gar kein herz verloren
steinbauten zu trennen ich bin eine
steile bitte keine war dass keine der
seiten
den quartz allerdings jarek heißt das
auch den quartz was zu essen
negativ ist auch in the border ich
möchte diesen lohn statt von ihm haben
ich habe angst ein wenig nach hinten
das video gibt einfach unterstützen
würde
gib mir mal den bogen nie das gleiche
putt
so was mal war jetzt das hier
ich würde sagen wir wollen uns erst mal
ganz kurz ein und ich beende hier meine
folge und dann seht ihr den rest der
spannenden aktionen auf dem kanal genau
wenn es euch gefallen hat diese etwas
chaotische folgen gegen ende
wir haben aber wieder was erreicht und
zwar sind wir in den keller gegangen
habe mir schon ein wenig erforscht und
war auf jeden fall richtig witzig die
nächste woche kommen bei komme bis
morgen